hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast ASTM International
Committee d 37 on cannabis the road to
consensus standards presented by Robert
Morgan
the director of technical committee
operations for ASTM International I am
Judy O'Rourke and I'll be your moderator
for today's event we're delighted to
bring you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots leverage is the
leading scientific social networking
website and producer of educational
virtual events and webinars before we
begin I would like to remind everyone
this event is interactive and we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
anytime you want during the presentation
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and type your questions into the
drop-down box that appears on the screen
well answer as many questions as we have
time for at the end of the presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the
help desk button located in the
promotional board at the bottom center
of your screen or use the ask a question
box to let us know that you're having a
problem this presentation is educational
and thus offers continuing education
credits please click on the continuing
education credits tab located in the top
right corner of the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming
Robert Morgan I will now turn the
presentation over to him
thank you very much Judy and a big thank
you to lab roads for inviting ASTM
International to give an update on our
newly formed committee D 37 on cannabis
and what I would like to do is talk to
you a little bit about ASTM and our
process with regard to standards
development
so a little bit about ASTM many of you
may be familiar with our organization
which has been around for a hundred and
twenty years and ASTM was established to
solve a problem that occurred back in
1898 with trains derail from the tracks
across the country and some scientists
and engineers got together and
determined that the quality of the steel
used in the rails was inconsistent and
therefore the trains would often derail
so the first standard was created in
ASTM back in 1898 for steel rails and
this was the first problem solved by
ASTM today we have over 30,000 members
that participate on a hundred and forty
seven different technical committees in
ASTM and we have over 12,000 standards
that have been developed by these
technical committees and these the
32,000 members that come from all
aspects of the industry ASTM is an
international standards development
organization we have 8,000 members from
135 countries around the world and as
you can see ASTM standards quite a few
of them are used in 75 countries around
the world ASTM is an accredited
standards development organization in
the US by ANSI in Canada by the Canadian
Standards Board and as well as ASTM is
an international standards development
organization as we conform to the World
Trade organization's principles of
consensus and those are openness and
transparency though ASTM is one of the
world's largest developer of
international standards
just to let you know ASTM standards
impact our lives on a daily basis the
gasoline that you put in your car is
based on an ASTM standard the fuel
that's used in airplanes around the
world are based on ASTM standards
construction materials steel concrete
all the way to things like children's
toys and the safety for the consumer in
all different aspects of Industry ASTM s
mission is to them to develop standards
that will improve the quality of
products and services while providing
protection for the consumers and the
environment
so what role do ASTM standards play well
as I just mentioned the primary role is
to ensure safety and quality and
reliability of products and services
ASTM provides a platform for innovation
to come into the marketplace and the end
result of the industry stakeholders that
develop the standards that that's built
on consensus have marketplace relevance
in helping everyone and improving the
quality as mentioned and as as
stakeholders who that is a term that we
use for the people that are on our
technical committees and they come from
industry they come from government they
come from academia and they all take an
active role in shaping the content of be
standards
so as I mentioned the ASTM has been
around for a hundred and twenty years
and what we do at ASTM in ASTM staff
which I am a member of is we provide the
infrastructure and tools for industry
stakeholders to collaborate on topics
and shape the content of standards we
also provide support for online
collaboration areas meetings support
administrative support editorial support
in trying to minimize those tasks for
our members so our members can focus on
the technical content of the standards
so it's an opportunity for us to bring
together the expertise and knowledge
from industry and participate in a
transparent open process to anyone that
is interested ASTM staff does not write
the standards we don't take any kind of
a role or advocacy with regard to the
content of standards we just provide the
framework and infrastructure to develop
and deliver those standards
so it's all about the power of
partnership in ASTM bringing the people
that make products people that buy the
products and people that consume the
products are all involved in the shaping
the content there's a neutral forum that
is a web based forum for development
people can work on their standards 24/7
and we have consensus based procedures
that protect the people that participate
in our standards development process and
it also creates a great partnership
between the private and public sector
with regard to the use of standards and
we'll touch upon that in a little bit
but in ASTM everyone has an equal say in
the development of the standard a large
company like ExxonMobil has the same
power as an individual that has an
interest in a particular topic ASTM has
a fair platform so everyone has an equal
say and a particular interest group
cannot dominate and shape and shape the
content for their advantage
so another
aspect of ASTM is we require a balance
of interest to participate for a
committee to be actively participating
in developing standards the primary
concept of balance in ASTM is the
producers of the products and services
that is being covered by the Technical
Committee cannot have more than 50% of
the votes when you collectively look at
the whole Technical Committee the users
and consumers and general interests can
have more than 50% of the votes in our
process but balance is maintained by
minimizing the role of the producers to
be not more than 50% so this is a
typical technical committee structure in
ASTM as I mentioned we have a hundred
and forty seven and it could be a
hundred and forty eight today main
committees in ASTM and as I mentioned
everything from steel petroleum textiles
sports equipment toy safety and sumer
products these are topics of ASTM main
committees and then underneath the main
committee umbrella or subcommittees that
are broken down into more specific
subject matter
and then underneath the subcommittee's
in ASTM we have task groups and task
groups are typically smaller groups of
individuals that have a desire to begin
the initial drafting of standards so
this is the typical structure of an ASTM
committee and consensus is achieved by
working your way up through this process
from the task group through the
subcommittee and ultimately through the
main committee
so oftentimes we get asked how long does
it take to develop a voluntary consensus
standard and it really depends on a lot
of variables
you know how complex is the subject
being addressed how urgent is the need
is this a safety concern that needs to
be addressed right away when those
aspects are known then that kind of
equates to the time that the volunteer
members on our technical committees are
able to devote to the project so we've
we've invested a lot of resources over
the years in our standards development
platform that has greatly assist in the
timeline and standards can get through
our process and approved in a short as
seven months and some complex standard
activities might be a year and a half to
get through the process that gets
consensus where the majority of the
people are on board with the standard to
allow it to get approved so what if
standards do in industry and what role
do they play in regulations this is a
question that's asked a lot and ASTM
standards it's important to note that
ASTM standards are developed voluntary
voluntarily by the members on our
technical committees and they're used
voluntarily in the marketplace now
oftentimes in ASTM standard is cited in
a contract and then of course that would
make it mandatory and it would need to
be followed it's also interesting that
the federal government back in 1995 has
the National Technology Transfer Act
Public Law 104 113 which directs
government agencies to rely on voluntary
standards developed by industry
stakeholders to use to support
regulation and laws by the federal
government so literally thousands of
ASTM standards are used in a variety of
levels of government whether that's the
federal level of the state level or
municipal level and countries around the
world rely on ASTM standards in support
of their regulations and laws
our programs and services that we
provide initially ASTM was primarily
focused on standards development
solutions were developed through
standards and when a Technical Committee
is created oftentimes they go through an
exercise pre standardization where they
will host symposia or technical
workshops to have information presented
to the committee's to help create ideas
for developing standards once the
standard gets through the process
achieves consensus ASTM has additional
services and programs to support the
standards we have product certification
we have inter laboratory study programs
that help in the development of standard
test methods ASTM will assist and put
putting together that inter laboratory
study distributes samples and help
create a standard that is reliable and
will have a precision and bias statement
along with it to say how accurate the
standard is doing what it says it's
doing in addition to that we have a
laboratory proficiency testing program
where people are able to share lab
results and able to compare their their
results with others performing the same
test so you are able to see how your
laboratory is performing we have a
training program that supports various
standards development activities some of
these stand but some of these training
programs are certificate programs and
can result in personnel certification
and ASTM latest platform for the
delivery of our technical information is
referred to as compass and this enables
us to deliver our standards to companies
and organizations and provide access
company-wide through our compass
platform
ASTM also is involved with partnerships
a lot of our partnerships are formal
informational we make co-brand or
standard with another organization that
has expertise in a specific topic and we
work to develop partnerships by
collecting data and sharing databases
and creating centers of excellence where
innovation is able to be discussed but
the most important partnership I think
that exists in ASTM is the partnership
that is that exists between the members
and the work that they're doing in the
committee they're able to to meet a lot
of people that are involved in the same
activities that they are and they're
able to exchange ideas and those ideas
often find their way in the form of
standards and improving the quality and
the safety of products so that was a
brief overview of ASTM in general and
and what I'd like to do now is tell you
about one of our latest technical
committees that was formed and that is
committee D 37 on cannabis so ASTM took
about 18 months to do research and due
diligence to review the landscape of the
cannabis industry to determine if in
fact this was a space that could benefit
from standards and during that 18-month
process we met with a variety of
stakeholders and we wanted to solicit
their input and identify gaps to see if
an organization like ASTM would be
beneficial to the industry and as a
result of that 18-month exploration last
year at ASTM headquarters back in
February we had a group of about 65
people representing
the stakeholder community as you see
described there on the slide and they
voted unanimously to form committee D 37
so as a result of this organizational
meeting they approved the scope and the
scope is quite simple and broad it's the
development and maintenance of standards
and guidance materials for cannabis and
its products and services and they broke
this topic D 37 on cannabis down to the
subcommittees that you see listed there
so these subcommittees it's important to
note is we have representation by the
people that cultivate cannabis the the
people that supply cannabis the people
that from the states that are involved
in regulating cannabis transportation
and security people are involved in our
activity as well as software developers
and accreditation bodies and elaborate
laboratories and of course researchers
from academia these are all the
stakeholder entities that are
represented in committee d 37 this slide
right now shows 280 members and it's a
little dated currently we have over 350
members representing the stakeholder
community that you see on the slide here
and as I mentioned about the format of
our committee structure a lot of the
work takes place more specifically
within the subcommittee's and you can
see the way the group voted to break
down the activity of cannabis we have
subcommittees on horticulture and
agriculture quality and math cloudy
management systems laboratory practices
processing and handling security and
transportation personnel training
assessment and credentialing as well as
terminology the executive committee is
consist of the officers the elected
officers of the committee which also
come from the stakeholder community
so in the process of forming the
committee and continuing at their first
meeting that was held last June in
Toronto Canada the topical areas that
were discussed as a need where standards
could fill are described on this slide
and you can see it's quite a busy slide
here I certainly won't won't read all
these topics but as you can see it's a
very thorough list of activities that
have been identified by the stakeholders
that standards could have an impact in
creating legitimacy for this industry
and that's the one thing that I have
noticed as I have inter interacted with
the variety of stakeholders in this
industry is they're very serious
scientists and and businessmen and
regulators and they recognize that this
industry has a need for legitimacy and
they see that being reached through the
formation of standards and and the
marketplace use of standards and that
makes me want to mention that one of the
reasons ASTM has been successful for 120
years is the idea of getting the right
stakeholders involved in the committee
having the right people at the table
making decisions on technical content
will result on what we refer to as a
marketplace relevant standard it will
have utility in the marketplace and the
industry will be willing to use these
standards as a way to improve the
quality of products and services and
taking into consideration safety for the
consumer as well as safety Keeney
environment this is an important aspect
of ASTM and committee D 37 on cannabis
seems to be well positioned with
with a great collection of stakeholders
that will be shaping the content of
standards and we're continuing to grow
and we're hoping that the folks that are
listening to this particular
presentation may have an interest in
participating and help shaping the
content of these standards for this
industry so I just would like to show
some of the activities that are
currently being pursued by the various
subcommittees in the Subcommittee on
cultivation and agriculture is working
on a standard practice for their
cultivation of medical grade cannabis
they're also working on a way to
classify the various horticultural
stages of cannabis the next subcommittee
D 3702 on laboratory is focused on
laboratory practices that would be used
to make sure that things like corrective
action and preventative action are in
place in the laboratory as they deal
with cultivation processing and testing
and distribution of the materials so
quality management systems will be
addressed in the Subcommittee on
laboratory working with the laboratory
subcommittee d 3703 on quality
management systems is focused on some
specific topics like developing a
standard test method for rapid analysis
of e.coli in cannabis products and
various quality assurance and quality
control measures that need to be in play
in the development of analytical methods
for laboratories subcommittee d 3704 on
processing handling seems to have the
the largest amount of momentum at this
time addressing activities of how
cannabis products should be packaged and
how they should be labeled
so the consumer can see precisely what
they are acquiring when they purchase
cannabis their addressing activities
like the role that water activity plays
in cannabis and and the importance of
that with regard to mold formation and
and any other kind of toxins that can
get into the plant they're developing
standards for extraction equipment and
methods for solvent based extraction
they're also looking forward techniques
for the refinement of cannabis extracts
and coming up with percents of the
various constituents that are found in
cannabis and making sure that that
information is included on the labeling
and packaging of cannabis materials an
interesting activity that was identified
I found that interesting had to do with
developing a standard on the
functionality of pressurized metered
dose inhalers which many of you may be
familiar with if you dealt with asthma
or if your children are dealing with
asthma or other lung issues the idea is
to make sure that these devices are
developed in a safe way and that the
components do not bring in any kind of
toxins into the delivery of the product
the next subcommittee is on security and
transportation and that the regulatory
community seems to be interested in in
these particular topics and a standard
practice for putting a video store video
surveillance system is is entering into
bow process right now there's also
standard practice being developed for
access control systems and also
intrusion detect detection systems all
these are important for the industry as
they move forward and evolve into a more
legitimate industry we have subcommittee
D 30 706 on personnel training
assessment and credentialing and right
now they are focused on working on a
standard practice for a certificate
program for the cannabis industry and
this will be around people that work in
laboratories and the qualifications that
they'll need to have to be considered a
qualified participant in a cannabis
activity so that concludes my
presentation on ASTM committee d 37 on
cannabis I hope that I generated some
interest from the community and we'd
certainly be interested in hearing your
questions and hopefully we'll have good
responses to them but hopefully will
stimulate your interest and have you get
involved in ASTM and help shape this
content so my contact information is
here ASTM as mentioned is a
international organization we have
offices in Canada Belgium Peru and China
and it's interesting to note that this
cannabis industry is truly a global
industry we had a well workshop in
Berlin last October that was well
attended had multiple countries
represented and they are excited to help
participate and shape the content in
global standards that will improve the
quality and products
services for this industry I thank you
very much for your time and I look
forward to hearing from you thank you
Robert for informative presentation we
will now start the live Q&A portion of
the webinar so if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click on the ask a question drop-down
box located on the far left of your
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click on the send button will answer
as many of your questions as we have
time for so let's get started our first
question is how our ASTM standards used
in the marketplace okay well as TM
standards as I as I mentioned are used
on a daily basis in the marketplace all
products that you can just about think
of that are in your home that your home
is made of the fuel for your car and
airplanes children's toys they all come
into play in making sure that the
quality of these products and services
are at the highest they can be while
also being safe for use so these
standards are developed by volunteer
members on the technical committees and
then they're used voluntarily by the
marketplace and the good news as I
mentioned if you have the right people
at the table making the decisions you'll
have a marketplace relevant document
that will have desire to be used also
they find their way into government
regulations as I stated and thousands of
ASTM standards are used to assist in
help shaping the content of regulations
again for keeping a safe environment or
protecting the consumer in one way or
another so ASTM standards are used daily
in the marketplace by by companies
around the world thank you for that
Robert how are ASTM standards different
from government regulations
well government regulate
stations are mandatory documents there
law and and they have to be followed
ASTM standards again are developed by
volunteers on our committees and when
they get into the marketplace they do
not necessarily have to be followed if
they're not part of some kind of mandate
in a contract or by a regulation it's up
to the marketplace to determine whether
they want to use the standard or not and
as I mentioned the good news is because
of the people and the commitment of the
volunteers and the stakeholders the end
result are standards that had utility
and the marketplace is driven to use
them because of the impact they have on
the products and services that are in
play with regard to the standards I
would like to once again thank Robert
Morgan for his presentation I would also
like to thank leverets for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through June 29
2018 you'll receive an email from lab
roots letting you know when this webcast
will be available for replay please
share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that is all for now thank you
for joining us we hope to feel again
soon bye